c'est mon bébé et jean jacques gosso
j'adore encore rentrée c'est à 5h30 du
matin puis m'ont montré pareillement
journée et les coques ou la musique
j'adore consorts qui s'est pratiquement
impossible d'arriver ce type en bois
puis même dans les journaux n'est pas ce
qu'on va sauver 300 clients qui a pas
grand monde qui va pas aussi que je veux
saluer ou prendre 35 ans il veut dire
bonjour qui les accueillit ça fait
partie de ma personnalité soit quelque
chose que je pense c'est que j'adore ça
sans jouer adoré ça cette pauvre bête de
plus 16 à 18 ans mais la tête remplie
omar à saint cyr au maroc et au lait
local et ont donné très prenant mais le
nom c'est toujours ce que j'ai fait dix
ans que la terrasse et où elle va
toujours rester le plus haut de jeudi
malgré que je dois admettre de la
pétanque commence à jeûner de la
compétition mais qui est elle
c'est ce premier cas plus d'importance
pour moi c'est l'achat de mon les
bateaux arrivent tous les jours tous les
jours j'en achète tous les jours je les
jours devrait en acheter combien ça
marche quand même 15 aujourd'hui je
rachetais peu près 150 caisses
c'était pas juste pour l'instant non ça
serait juste pour le restaurant il
serait dix fois plus donc ça fait cher
non il naquit voiture balai dans les
poissonneries employés des usines de
transformation îlots qui va aller les
autres sénégalais un peu partout puis-je
attaché à ma région juge
j'ai grandi en entier ces poisons que
cherche d'humains c'est par hasard que
je ne sais pas de la couleur que je fais
c'est ce qu'on mange à neige c'est
l'accusé la maison des enfants grand dam
d'un mois j'ai grandi là dedans
martial la coop steen et un bouillant
cas c'est un pot de maquereaux bon ok
c'est vraiment notre cuisine si si j'ai
rien inventé ce sens que chez toi ta
mère sans doute on passe avec laurent
absolument absolument maintenant sud
elle y reste à peine 400 habitants mais
il ya 67 permis de pêche sur mon jeu ça
donne une idée
non mais ça fait partie du mode de vie
demain
la vidéo là que le métal ou parce que
niveau hockey
ça vaut la peine bien sûr dé l'unesco
coi comportant des gens sont très
accueillants si typique des acadiens qui
dévie belles plages à découvrir sur
l'île quand on voit quelqu'un eut pris
chez l'ex semaine que les beaux sentiers
oubliés cosip et la fameuse avions reçu
au visage en aucun cas aller creuser qui
s'est pas partout des visages côtier de
pêcheurs comme ça c'est spécial c'est
vraiment le dit 75-68 s'il est trop bien
ce mardi dans le 20 km à 372 là où ils
font se trouvait en face de lâcher parce
que tu vois c'est bien les montagnes l'a
gaspillé une belle vision je pense entre
journée surtout bien manger ouais